alleged victims of r.kelly are speaking
out for the first time since the CBS
this morning interview where the singer
defended himself against charges of
abusing underage girls well he's still
in jail this morning for failing to pay
child support though his manager says he
expects Kelly's release later today
Kelly has pleaded not guilty in Chicago
to ten counts of aggravated criminal
sexual abuse police in Detroit's say
they want to speak with a woman who
claims that Kelly abused her when she
was 13 during this week's interview he
denied all such allegations against him
have you ever had said no and he went
under the age of seven no never
no tarika Duncan spoke with two of his
accusers and the mother of a third she
is in Chicago with their thoughts on the
art Kelly interview tarika good morning
good morning all three women said that
moment when our Kelly stood up it
brought back horrifying memories last
night I spoke to Michelle Cramer who
says she believes her daughter was
abused by our Kelly for nearly a decade
you saw the interview that our Kelly did
with Gill came I saw some of the little
clips you can't watch the whole thing
can't watch full stories you know I can
watch full stories I just can't do
circus acts
Michelle Cramer says her daughter 27
year old Dominique Gardner almost threw
the remote at the TV as they watched
parts of the interview everything he
said he jumped up
she said she remember the rage when she
wasn't doing well here sort of do or
tell her to do or he got upset about
something he walked too slow you you did
whatever and it was a punishment
in the docu-series surviving our Kellie
Kramer tracked down her daughter to the
hotel where she was staying with our
Kelly cameras followed their hasty
getaway we ran out of there like the
master was coming for us that moment
came up during Gale Kings interview with
him this is just the beginning
but you can say what Dominique's mother
said when she had to rescue her daughter
rescue be careful and that Dominique was
held against her will
I'm just telling you that these are the
elements you're not just telling me this
you're saying this Gail you're breaking
my heart you're saying it's like you
believe it Kramer says there's a good
reason to believe it because it's true
well Kelly has denied ever abusing women
Kramer says her daughter told her
several times she was beaten and starved
for days when my daughter came home she
was 98 pounds when she left to be with
him she was 125 I can't understand
somebody say they love you and then the
same throughout spending your mother
face that's what you say our Kelly did
to your daughter yes other women who
have accused our Kelly of abuse people
would say me had a wide range of
reactions to the interview when he
started screaming it terrified me Asante
McGee says Kelly subjected her to mental
and sexual abuse while she lived with
him for three weeks
she told us she turned off her
television there was nothing that I felt
sorry about him for because I know the
type of man he is and I know he would
cry at the drop of a dime he's a great
performer of course I expected him to
call us liars another former girlfriend
of Kelly's Kitty Jones saw things a
little differently
she says she felt sad watching the man
she claims beat her I cried because I
still saw the person that I fell in love
with and I couldn't help but wonder like
why didn't someone step in and help him
earlier
you know Michele Kramer says she
still cannot handle hearing all of what
she believes happened to her daughter
and fear quote that she might end up
where our Kelly is in jail
Michele Kramer tells us that dominique
has now been home for nine months and is
currently seeing a therapist Gail yeah I
suspect everybody's going to need to say
see a therapist by the time this is all
over however it turns out Thank You
jurika